it is official apple is working on
fixing the ipad and giving us what we've
been asking for for years now and i'm
not just talking about leaks or rumors
and people that are in the industry this
is straight from apple because they were
just granted new patents that they filed
showing off connecting the ipad to a
keyboard and getting a full mac os like
system we have tons of images a lot of
detail so we're going to take a look at
all of those they're also going to take
a look at what people have been
mentioning about software that's being
created and worked on as well as when we
can expect to get this into our hands
now you guys know that when the ipad
with the m1 chip came out it blew our
minds it blew your minds it was an
amazing step in terms of hardware but
when it came time for the software side
ipad os 15 really disappointed
us we have this crazy hardware we have
thunderbolt we have these amazing
displays
but the software is very lacking and you
still have issues for example you can't
even format a hard drive if you don't
have a mac computer a lot of times it
gets corrupted and it's just crazy the
certain limitations that we have and of
course so many of us were expecting pro
applications for this hardware but that
didn't come out well now we have a ton
of good news now it is so exciting cool
to finally have confirmation of this
because we've been talking about the
recent leaks and info for example apple
working on a version of final cut for
ipad apple also working on guest
accounts to give this device more
flexibility and functionality and of
course mixer which is what they are
calling it internally based on sources
which is the smart system for ipad os
that is also shown in these patents now
you'll still have apps full screen but
then when you connect it to a keyboard
it can shrink and run like an actual
desktop operating system with way better
multi-tasking now good news for those of
you guys who don't have or don't want to
buy an expensive keyboard apple's also
working on extra functionality just with
the apple pencil for example having
stacks in the dock that are activated
they've been working on this for pretty
much a year now and all this info and
schematics have led to multiple
high-level people talking about this new
system for ipad os for example we have
mark german who works for bloomberg
that is one of the most accurate leakers
with a lot of insider information
talking about how this could work with
his what he calls pro mode which kicks
in when you connect a keyboard and a
trackpad which is exactly what these
patents show and alongside the standard
controls that we now have the extra
features and capabilities with the apple
pencil which apple has been working on
and then of course that pro mode that
just makes it much more usable and
professional for example mac like
multitasking with the ability to have
several windows opened up and stacked
with each other which is pretty much
spot on and a much more powerful dock
where you can pin files you can minimize
apps be able to go into shortcuts just
like mac os and then with that just a
proper desktop where you can have
different folder setup links it just
gives you a lot of info and also small
apps that you could just launch and have
open and now let's just go ahead and
look at those patents this is on
patently apple which tracks all of
apple's patents and right away we see
what looks pretty much like a laptop
with a detachable uh display but it's
thicker so it is an ipad we see it
disconnected here on the left with a
little short but long connector that
gives us a standard hinge which makes it
just like a laptop where you have full
control of your angle which you don't
get as much control with the apple magic
keyboard now i do want to point out that
these patterns aren't exactly what comes
out certain things are shown for the
patent purposes but the look could be
different and then as soon as it is
connected here we have this which is
huge to confirm what apple's working on
it literally looks like mac os we have
two windows that are labeled window one
window two one above the other so it's
not the side by side multitasking that
we have right now that is really limited
and at the same time we have icons there
on the left hand side and up top look at
that we have finder
file edit view go window help this is
crazy this is exactly what i wanted for
the m1 ipad
pro
now we can continue scrolling down here
and we get a lot more information uh on
this design so we have the apple's
patent which has a hinged keyboard
accessory that has multiple installation
modes for a tablet computing device so
it is for a tablet now what really
stands out to me other than the look
here is the connector now once again
this could be different for the actual
version but this is not what we have on
the current ipads now we have the
connector right there at the bottom and
it shows exactly where it connects on
that hinge and we have that really you
know long hinge right there which they
call the coupling mechanism now the
smart connector is on the back
underneath the apple logo right now so
that would require a keyboard like the
magic keyboard which has a full back
that magnetizes to it and makes that
connection but this looks different that
also gives me some concerns which we'll
talk about in a bit but let's keep
looking now we have this connection
right here we have the full
adjustability they have a lot of
different figures and then we also see
it completely closed right there with
the hinge that gets stuck to it without
any backing now when we scroll down here
we get extra info for example over here
we see the apple pencil there and how
it's
being held on pretty much to where what
looks like that hinge so it's almost
like another spot for it to magnetize we
see those little two sections for
magnets
and then when you do that we have a
little pop down that gives you the
battery information
and then over here we see that
connection interface with three pins
just like the smart connector but in a
different spot
and right above that we actually see
sections for magnets both on the
keyboard accessory and on the ipad
itself and then what's very interesting
is right here figure 8b
it says that we have a camera a
projector a light and a microphone
right there in that spot now that's very
interesting because if we go ahead and
look down and we actually read these
notes it says that that image that apple
made could provide a connection
interface that support adding other
accessories such as a camera a projector
microphone or a light now that is very
weird but there we have it we have all
this detail on design features things
that are patenting and exactly what they
want to do now here is where it gets
weirder much weirder we scroll down and
we look at this image which apple's
calling the modularized computing and
input devices
so we have a screen here we have the
keyboard and we also have that dock but
it looks like the keyboard is removable
it pops off and then
106 looks like another ipad so here we
have you know the standard connection
with the keyboard and you actually see a
little slim line showing where the
keyboard can pop off which is weird and
then
another
tablet or maybe just a screen connecting
to that giving us this double laptop
with twice the screen space now this
just seems weird it's called the dual
display configuration this is from apple
what they patented and then that brings
me to mark german's
leak talking about a mysterious 20 inch
foldable that could be a macbook ipad
hybrid with a touchscreen keyboard now
when this came out i thought it was
crazy like who would want that would
apple really work on that we don't have
a foldable iphone yet
but he was talking about apple working
on this
and now we actually have apple's patent
that they filed and it was approved for
just this actual device
very crazy now personally i don't care
about this i care about running a
desktop ui hopefully mac os and then pro
apps
for the ipad giving us capabilities that
could actually match the hardware we
have the am1 chip we have the same eight
and 16 gigs of ram just like in a
macbook it's running you know apple's
own chips so all the software is capable
to run on there it's just apple that is
holding them you know everything back
and that's why so many people were upset
with the ipad now with all this said
what are some main questions we have
well first when will this come out going
back to this illustration which is what
apple is working on in may of 2021 a
year ago this is for ipad os 16 showing
these updates right here that means that
some of these new features and things
apple's been working on are going to be
coming out soon in a month we have wwdc
with the beta launches and then of
course in the fall of them coming out
now the question is is this new ui going
to be coming out at that same time well
we will find out very soon but before
that what really makes me think that
this needs to come sooner than later is
because
ipad sales have been falling
dramatically lately they fell 14
which is huge while at the same time
everything else iphones max the sales
have been increasing and why are people
not buying ipads well the macs are
incredible they're very fast battery
life is great you have all the software
on the ipad even though we have m1 even
on the ipad air now the software just
isn't there so if apple really wants to
start selling more ipads more
accessories it would make sense to
finally give us the software been asking
for and push up sales that way now the
second question is which ipads will this
support well the info that we have even
before these patents and about apple
developing the smart system is that it
should be m1 ipad exclusive now it makes
sense for multiple ways first off you
know they're going to be for the more
expensive ipads which now are cheaper
thanks to the ipad air
and second with that same m1 chip being
in there it's the same one that's in the
macbook so as far as software and tuning
it should work fairly easily and that
makes it a lot nicer now the other
question is what do you need for this to
happen is it going to be with just the
magic keyboard or is it going to be with
something that is more expensive like we
saw in those patents these images show
us a whole nother keyboard accessory
with a different dock with different
pins of course it doesn't have to be
like this this could be just for their
patent purposes but it would be terrible
if apple decided hey we're gonna have
mac os on ipad but we want you to buy
the brand new ipad with this new
keyboard in order uh for you to get that
now that would get a lot of people to
upgrade from their older ipad pros but
it would be a bummer and a lot of people
would be upset now possibly this could
be a new ipad with some different
changes and then you know if you get the
new one you're just going to have this
newark style of device but i really hope
it's gonna come to all the ipads that
have the m1 chip i think that would make
a lot of sense so there you guys go we
have all these patents all the leaks
everything is coming together we have
one month until wwdc go ahead and click
that subscribe button above to help us
reach our goal of one million
subscribers we're gonna be covering
everything at that event check out one
of these great videos right over here
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
you